موسكو تضع توسع في الناتو ضمن التهديدات
الحربيه الى خانه عسكريا جديدا على حدود
فنلندا
نائب رئيس المكتب
يستقيل والاخير يمنع كبار المسؤولين من
السفر الا بمبرر
على اصدار تشريع جديد لحظر الاسلحه بعد
مقتل 18 شخصا في ثلاث حوادث متتاليه في
كاليفورنيا
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم مشاهدينا بكل خير اهلا
بكم في هذه النشره مشاهدينا البدايه من
موسكو حيث ادخلت القياده العسكريه الروسيه
حلف الناتو فنلندا والسويد من دائره
التهديد الحربي في هذا السياق قال رئيس
هيئه الاركان العام روسيه
الاصلاحات العسكريه الروسيه الجديده تاخذ
في الاعتبار التوسع المحتمل حل في شمال
الاطلسي واكد رئيس الاركان الجديد في اول
تعليق النموذج
الاصلاحات الجديده والتي بموجبها سيضاف
فيلقونا عسكري الى كارينا في شمال روسيا
على الحدود مع فلندا الى جانب ان شاء الله
هذا هو اعلى متحدث باسم شركه رهن مثال
الدفاعيه الالمانيه ان الشركه قد تسلم 139
دبابه ليوبارد الى اوكرانيا اذا لزم الامر
واضاف ان شركه يمكنها تسليم 29 دبابه منها
بحلول اربريل الى مايو وبامكانيه 22 دبابه
في نهايه عام 2023 او او الى عام 2024
مشيرا الى قدره الشركه على تسليم اوكرانيا
ثمان 88 دبابه ليوبارد 1 الاقدم لكن دون
اعطاء اطار زملا محتمل
الحرب في اوكرانيا مستعره تواجهها حرب
اخرى بين قاده اوروبا في خضم معركه ايراده
الجدل والاتهامات المواجهه لبرلين
بالتقاعس عن دعم كيف على منسوبها بين
الحلفاء الغربيين المانيا في الاتهامات
تاره وتقول انها ليست حجره عثره في طريق
تزويد اوكرانيا بالعتاد
لكن اذا طلب منا فلن نقف في الطريق
الدبابات المطلوبه ليس للتجول في الشارع
ليدافع الاوكرانيون عن انفسهم افهموا مدى
اهميته هذه الدبابات وندرك ذلك تماما لهذا
السبب نحن مع جميع شركائنا في عمليه
المشاورات
وتاره اخرى تدعو الى التحلي بالصبر بشان
قرار ارسال دبابات اليو بارتس باي الى
الجيش الاوكراني فمصلحه بيرلين تتمثل في
اتخاذ القرار بعنايه لانه قد يؤثر عليها
يقول وزير الدفاع الالماني
تردد برلين دفع بولندا الى الاعلان عن
تشكيل تحالف يضم البلدان التي تملك دبابات
اليو بارك والمستعده لتقديمها الى كاف
منتقده المانيا على اضاعه الوقت
الى اوكرانيا وحتى لو لم نحصل على هذه
الموافقه سنستمر في تسليم دباباتنا مع
الاخرين الى اوكرانيا
تطورات تاتي في وقت تعمل فيه المانيا على
حساب كل المعادلات وعدم التورث في حرب
مباشر
الا اذا فعلت واشنطن الامر نفسه
بلال البوجتين العربيه
في جبهات الاماميه للقتال حيث شيد الجنود
اوكراها مجموعه من تلك الخنادق بالمقابل
حفره القوات الروسيه خنادق ممثله وعززتها
في المناطق الواقعه تحت سيطرتها
هنا ليس هذا هو السلاح فقط سلاح الاخر امر
الخنادق
لايف تنتشر هذه الخنادق بالاضافه الى
خنادق اخرى تم تشيدها على طول حدود
اوكرانيا مع بلاروسيا لتشكل جميعها خط
الدفاع الاول للجنود الاوكرانيين في
مواجهه روسيا يعيش المجندون الشتاء في
الخنادق مثل جميع الجنود منذ قرون النظم
تشكل تلك المواقع ما صدقت دفاعيه مصممه
للوقوف في وجه اي هجوم كما تعطل الخنادق
والتحصنات اي توغل محتمل في تلك المنطقه
لكن الارضيه الصلبه التي يفضلها بنات هذه
الخنادق قد تجعل من السهل على العدو
التقدم وقد يشكل موقعهم احيانا هدفا سهلا
ان تم استهدافه من على القمم العاليه
تستقبل تلك هنادي جنود العدو مسلحين
بالقنابل اليدويه والبنادق الرشاشه
ويحاولون الاقتراب قدر المستطاع لمجرد
القاء القنابل اليدويه على الخنادق في
معظم الاحيان يموت الجنود في كتل من الطين
الملوثه على حدود هذه الخنادق
بين الحياه والموت تقف ارواح الجنود بين
جدارين تحت الارض بين الصقيع ونيران
المدافع متسلحين بخنادقهم في المنطقه
المحرمه
الخناقه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
ازمه تضرب مكتب رئيس رنسكي فبعد استقاله
مستشاره اليكسيس تويتش قبل ايام اعلن نائب
رئيس المكتب الرئاسي لدى الرئاسه لدى
الرئيس فودافون
التي تاتي وسط شبهات فساد تلاحق غدا
يلمسؤوليه الاوكرانيين في هذا الاطار اعلى
رئيس ان المسؤولين الاوكرانيين لن يتمكنوا
من مغادره اوكرانيا الا لرحلات العمل خلال
فتره الاحكام العرفيه وامر زي الاسكيمو
الوزراء باجراء التغيرات على قواعد عبور
الدوله في غضون خمسه ايام الرئيس
الاوكراني قال ان المعركه من اجل ضم باص
والجنوب مستمره واين قوته سترد على
الضربات الروسيه وتناقلت وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيا قاده الادارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في سامي
في الشهر الايراني مشاهدينا قالوا المتحدث
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني ان بلاده ستعلن عن قائمه جديده من
العقوبات ضد منتهي في حقوق الانسان في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا على حد قوله
جاء هذا بعد ان رئاسه السويديه الاتحاد
الاوروبي انه وزراء التكتل اقر حزمه جديده
من العقوبه على ايران بسبب قمع الاحتجاجات
هذا هو اعتبرت وزيره الخارج المانيا
على قوائم لكن هذه الخطوه اثار الجدران من
حيث الالي القانونيه لتنفيذها حيث يتطلب
تصنيف الحركه الثوري منظمه الارهابيه
قرارا قضائيا اوروبيا هذا ما اكد عليه
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي اضاف على التكتل لا يمكنه
ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني على قائمه
الكيانات الارهابيه الا بعد صدور قرار من
محكمه في الاتحاد تفيد بذلك وهذا يتطلب
بحسب ابريل ادانه قانونيه ملموسه
وتيج سامسونج
ادراج الحرس الثوري الايرانيه على قوائم
الارهاب دون قرار قضائي قرار المحكمه اولا
فلا يمكن تصنيف اي شخص بسبب كره له لذلك
يجب اصدار القرار عندما تقر دوله اوروبيه
حكما رسميا بناء على اسس قويه حينها يمكن
العمل على المستوى الاوروبي
اسره السجين الايراني
بعد اسبوع من دخوله في الاضراب واعلن انه
يعاني من انخفاض الضغط وفقدان الوزن وكان
المذي بعث رساله الى رئيس الولايات
المتحده
عن الطعام وانتقد ايضا الرؤساء امريكا
السابقين نماذج قال في رسالته ان كل ما
يريده هو ان يخصص بيض دقيقه واحده من وقته
لمعاناه الرهائن الامريكيين في نعم وحكم
على ثياماك ووالده باقي النماذي بالسجن 10
سنوات بتهمه التجسس لصالح واشنطن لكنهما
والحكومه الامريكيه نفاياتهما
نستطيع مستمره مشاهدينا او فيها بعد
الفاصل الصحه العالميه تدرس النصح بعدم
استخدام ادويه السعال للاطفال بسبب مواد
سامه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في العراق
تتطور ازمه الدينار العراقي المتهاوي امام
الدولار وستتحرك عاجل من السلطات السيطره
على الاسماء حيث ينتظر ان تكشف اليوم
وزاره الداخليه عن حصيله مكافحه شبكات
التهريبي والجريمه الاقتصاديه في هذا
السياق مشاهدين قال رئيس الوزراء محمد
السوداني من البلاد كانت تبيع 300 اوبل
300 مليون دولار في اليوم الواحد فيما عجز
الاقتصاديون عن تفسير ما الذي يستورده
العراق حتى يبيع يوميا بهذا الرقم
وشدد السوداني على ان حكومه الجهاد في
تطبيق الصحيه بل الصحيحه التي تضمن
المحافظه على المال العام
النافذه نافذه بيع العمله فيها هدر وفيها
اموال تخرج
بغطاء تجاره غير مشروعه تهريب غسيل اموال
شتتهم
والتحليلات
واغلبها صحيح يعني لا ليس في اطار التهمه
كنا نبيع 300 مليون دولار في اليوم الواحد
وكل الاقتصاديين والمختصين يقفون عاجزين
على تفسير انه ما الذي يستورده العراق
يوميا حتى يبيع 300 مليون دولار
الاتحاديه في تقريرها لعام 2020 عن مقدار
الضرر الذي الذي طار الخزينه العامه
والبالغ ما يقرب من اربعه دينار والسبب
عملياته فساد عبر
ازمه الدولار بالعراق واشنط رصدت عمليه
بيع غير قانونيه للعمله تطبيق بفواتير
مصارف عراقيه كشف الكثير من الفواتير
المزوره
من بيع الدولار كعوب
الاتحاديه عام 2022 اكبر عمليه فساد تتم
من خلال مزاد العمره
[موسيقى]
وخزينه
العراقيه
تابعه لايران
نشير مشاهدين على هذا الخبر العاجل خارجيه
فنلندا من الافضل ان تكون المحادثات مع
تركيا بشان الانضمام ثلاثيه مع السويد
والسنوات
حول هذا الموضوع الى ملف العراق مره اخرى
من بغداد ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه منتظر
الرشيد اهلا بك منتظر نحن اا نتوقع ايضا
عقد مؤتمر صحفي لوزاره الداخليه العراقيه
اليوم حتى يكون معنا المشاهد في الصوره ما
الذي استدعى عقد هذا المؤتمر في هذا
التوقيت منتظر
يعني هذا المؤتمر الصحفي للمتحدث باسم
وزاره الداخليه
والذي
طبعا عن جمله من القضايا من هذه القضايا
عمليات تهريب النفط والشبكات المتورطه
بعمليات التهريب هو التي تم القاء القبض
على عاده ليس بالقليل منها خلال الفتره
القليله الماضيه اخرها امس شبكه لتهريب
النفط همم في كركوك اما الشقه الثانيه
الذي سيتحدث عنه طبعا همم المتحدث باسم
وزاره الداخليه وهو مكافحه الشبكات
التلاعب طبعا بالعمله تحديدا الدولاب
وايضا التلاعب بالاسعار خصوصا في السوق
السوداء همم وزاره الداخليه شنت حمل همم
حمله اعتقالها حمله تفتيش حمله مطارده
طبعا لهؤلاء الذين يضاربون طبعا بالدولار
في الاسواق السوداء وبالتالي ساهموا في
هذه الازمه لان همم المصارف الحكوميه
البنك المركزيه بيع الدولار بسعر
بينما تجده في السوق السوداء اكبر بكثير
مما هو عليه الحال داخل المصارف الحكوميه
وحتى المصارف الاهليه بالتالي هذا الفرق
يعود طبعا الى مضاربين يعود الى رجال
اعمال يعود الى تجار وربما الى قوى سياسيه
كما تتحدث بعض المصادر المقربه من
السوداني تريد خلق مثل هذه الازمه هناك
الشبكات كبيره هناك قوى هناك من يقوم
بعمليات تهريب كبرى طبعا للدولار الى خارج
البلاد برا همم باتجاه تركيا وايران وحتى
طبعا الى سوريا ومن ثم هناك عمليات تهريج
العمله الى لبنان والى بلدان اخرى اذن هذا
الملف واشنطن تدخل طبعا لقافه مجموعه من
الضوابط على الحكومه العراقيه نعم حكومه
السودان ايضا تريد ان تنهي هذا الملف لكن
الثمن كان ارتفاع سعر الصرف طبعا في
الاسواق وبالتاريخ
الحكومي وان كان لبعض يراه متاخرا هل يعور
عليه بشكل كبير في تحجيم الفساد في البلاد
وايضا عوده الدينار العراقي الى مستوى
الطبيعي
يعني كل الاجراءات التي اتخذت خلال
اليومين الماضيين على راسها طبعا اقاله
محافظ البنك المركزي وبالتالي تعيين بديل
له اضافه الى سلسله من الضوابط والاجراءات
في من خلال توفير الدولار باعداد او
بكميات كبيره داخل المصارف الحكوميه فتح
هذه المصارف حتى في ايام العطل دعوه
التجار ومن يريد شراء الدولار للذهاب الى
هذه المصارف هذه هي الاجراءات ساهم طبعا
في خفض سعر الصرف طبعا بنسبه ليست
بالقليله من خلال 24 ساعه اليوم سعر الصرف
الخفض كثيرا اما كان عليه في الايام
الماضيه يتوقع مزيدا من الانخفاض اذا ما
وصلت الحكومه طبعا اتخاذ هذه الاجراءات
التي وعدت بها وبدات تنفيذها نعم مرتضى ان
احنا نكون في متابعه معك فيما سيطرح في
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي لوزاره الداخليه شكرا
لك من بغداد كتب معنا مراسل العربيه
اعلنت وزاره العدل واداره مكافحه الارهاب
الفرنسيه اعاده 47 شخصا كانوا في مخيمات
بشمال شرق سوريا الى فرنسا بينهم 15 امراه
واثنين وثلاثين قاصرا وزاره الخارجيه
فرنسا افادت من جهتها بانه تم تسليم
القاصرين الى الاجهزه المكلفه بمساعده
الاطفال وستقدم لهم متابعه طبيه اجتماعيه
مضيفه ان السيدات البالغات جارها تسليمهن
الى السلطه القضائيه المختصه
يصادف اليوم الثلاثاء اليوم الدوليه
للتعليم الا ان افغانستان هي الدوله
الوحيده التي تمنع فيها الفتيات من الذهاب
الى المدرسه لكن الافغانيه دفعنا عن حقهن
عبر المدارس السريه المزيد في التقرير
التالي
[موسيقى]
ات عن الحياه العامه
وحرمتهن من حقوقهن الاساسيه احدها الحق في
التعليم الا ان الافغانيات دافعنا عنه
بسلاح المدارس السريه في كل صباح باحد
افقر احياء العاصمه كابل تجتمع فتيات في
منزل للدراسه هو جزء من شبكه من ثماني
مدارس في خمس مدن تقدم خدماتها سرا
وبالمجان تدعمها منظمه افغانيات تعمل في
المناطق شديده التاثر بحظر مدارس البنات
حظر طالبان لتعليم الفتيات تزامنا مع
سيطرتها على الحكم في افغانستان عام 2021
الا ان هناك ما يقرب من 250 امراه تاثرنا
بحذر طالبان للتعليم في التسعينات هنا
انفسهن بتنايب حثنا عنهم مجددا في المدارس
السريه رغم الخطر الذي يواجه المعلمات
والطالبات الا انهن يتمسكن بالتعليم
المتحديات احتمال التعرض للاعت والقتل
ويتحايلنا على اعين عناصر الحركه باخفاء
ادوات التعليم وسلك طرق طويله ومختلفه
نتركو كتبنا في المنزل وفي الفصل اذا كان
لدينا واجب منزلي نكتبه على قطعه من الورق
بقلمنا ونضعه في جيبنا
امام المدارس السريه ليس سهلا اذ ان
سريتها ثانيه عدم حصول الطالبات على
شهادات رسميه وتدق ناقوسم خوف ظهور جيل من
الفتيات عشنا حاضرا وسط الحرب والقمع
وبانتظارهن مستقبل رائع روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى الى هذا الخبر العاجل تقول يجب
ان نفكر بالانضمام الى النت بدون السويد
قبل خارجيه فنلندا تقول اتفقنا مع تركيا
على الثمار التواصل كما كان في السابق
وخارج في الهند ايضا تتحدث عن انهم يا
افضل ان تكون المحادثات مع تركيا بشان
الانضمام الى ان يتم ثلاثيه مع السويد
بالعوده
الذي اودى بحياه احد عشر شخصا واجرها
اخرين في امريكا قتل سبعه اشخاص في اطلاق
نار في موقع عين شمال
على بعد حوالي 50 كلم جنوب سان فرانسيسكو
وتم القائمه القبض على الجاني فيما لم
تعرف بعد دوافع الهجوم
عقبالك حتى الرئيس الامريكي على تمرير
تشريع جديد لحضر اسلحه الهجوميه في
الولايات المتحده في ضوء موجه اطلاق النار
الاخيره
ونقل بيان عن الرئيس بيض قوله اريد من
مجلس الكونغرس التصرف بسرعه وتسليم تشريع
حظر الاسلحه الهجوميه هذا الى مكتبي واضاف
البيان ان سيناتور الديمقراطيه ديان
فاينشتاين ستقرح مره اخرى في مجلس الشيوخ
مسوده قانون يحضر الاسلحه الهجوميه
بالاضافه الى تشريع يرفع سن شراءها الى
واحد و20 عاما
في شيء اخر افاد البيت الابيض بان وزاره
العدل فتشت منزل رئيس جو بارد الجمعه بعد
عرض طوعي وسبقيه قدمهم محاميه الشخصيه
الوزراء وقال بو باور محامي رئيس ان بعض
الوثائق السريه ترجع الى فتره ولايه بيض
في مجلس الشيوخ مضيفا ان وثائق اخرى كانت
من فتره توليه منصبا نائب الرئيس في اداره
الرئيس الاسبق اوباما من 2009 حتى 2017
منظمه الصحه العالميه اشارت الى وجود
المواد سامه في ادويه السعال خطيره على
حياه الاطفال
اعلنا وزير الطاقه الباكستانيه عن استعاده
الطاقه الكهربائيه في جميع انحاء باكستان
بعد انقطاعها في سائر انحاء البلاد منذ
ساعه مبكرا من صباح امس الاثنين وفي حين
لم يعلن وزير الطاقه الباكستاني السبب
المباشر لانهيار شبكه الكهرباء كشف عن
تحقيق تجاه السلطات في امكانيه وجود تدخل
خارجي كهجو من عن طريق الانترنت
نائب رئيس المكتب الرئيسي يستقيل والاخير
يمنع كبار المسؤولين من السفر الا بمبرر
بايدي مصر على اصدار تشريع جديد لحضر
الاسلحه بعد مقتل 18 شخصا في ثلاث حوادث
متتاليه في كاليفورنيا
[موسيقى]